Speaker 1: sinformation. The Russian invasion
of Ukraine provides an opportunity for some
introspection, which we want to do right now. It's
very easy and common for us in the United States
to hear, Oh, the North Korean people
are being told this and they believe it,
or the Russian people are being told this
and they believe it. Like Russia's invasion
of Ukraine is a moral and correct action because
it's all neo-Nazis in Ukraine and there's biolabs
and they want to be Russia in any way. You know,
whatever. And we we hear that and many of us say,
these people, how do they fall for this stuff?
You know, we're we're Americans. We don't fall
for this sort of stuff. But actually, many
Americans fall for exactly this sort of stuff.
So the context is, how could they really
believe that? Here is Julia Ioffe on MSNBC
saying, Hey, you know what? It happens in the
United States, too. Take a listen to this very,
very interesting discussion with Stephanie Ruhle.
Speaker 3: You know, every time I'm asked
by Americans, Do Russians really believe this
stuff? Like, How can they believe this stuff?
As if we don't have the same
thing happening here? You have,
what, 40 percent of the population that of the
American population that was convinced just
in one year that Donald Trump actually won the
2020 election? Right. Russians have been subjected
to this kind of disinformation for far, far
longer. So it shouldn't be all that surprising.
Americans fall for too pretty easily.
Speaker 1: True. This is a really this
is a big topic when one of the earliest stories
I remember where I said, Wow, people just believe
stuff without evidence. All the time was in the
aftermath of the invasion to the Iraq War of 2003.
There was. It's ingrained in my mind like it
was just yesterday. I remember covering it in
the early days of the show. In 2005 2006, there
was a study done by Pippa which asked Americans
basically three fundamental questions who did
911 are were weapons of mass destruction found
in Iraq? And does the world generally approve or
disapprove of the American invasion of Iraq? And
we found the study found that Fox News viewers,
people who primarily got their information
from Fox News were far more likely to believe,
yes, we did find weapons of mass destruction in
Iraq when we did not. They were far more likely to
believe yes, Saddam was responsible for nine 11,
and they were far more likely to believe that the
global community approved of the American invasion
of Iraq, which it did not which it did not that
it was factually untrue and nothing has really
changed. In fact, it's kind of gotten worse with
social media, echo chambers and filter bubbles
in the last couple of years. Yes, of course,
the Trump one thing so many Republicans falling
for Trump actually was the winner of the 2020
election, but also beliefs about vaccines, right?
Much of the country believes the pandemic is over.
And yet a thousand Americans are dying a day,
and we're going to look at some record case
numbers later on in the program today. We seem to
be heading for another spike. The only question is
how big will it be? It's been how many generations
since the Civil War and we still have, I
mean, conservatively. Some tens of millions
of Americans who believe the Civil War was not
about preserving slavery, they've fallen for that,
and that's hundreds of years ago and on and
on and on. A huge portion of Americans believe
demonstrably untrue things. And yet we laugh
at Russia that some people have fallen for
decades of Kremlin propaganda, or we laugh at
North Korea. Now there's one other layer to this,
which is that in many of these countries,
let me see how I can say this in the U.S.,
there's really no repercussion to admitting
you believe a lot of this stuff. You know,
occasionally there will be. Sort of like social
consequences, you'll be laughed at, and if what
you say is really, really vile, you might lose
your job. But generally speaking in the US,
if people believe Trump won the 2020 election,
they'll just say it. In countries like Russia
and North Korea, to some degree, the people, even
if they don't believe this stuff, are more likely
to say that they do because the repercussions can
be more serious for saying, I don't believe what
the government's telling me. So in reality, it may
actually be worse in the United States. And what I
mean by that is when you ask people in Russia
and North Korea and China, whatever else, do
you believe this thing? Some of the people who say
yes are saying it to stay on the good side of the
government, which is not really a factor here in
the United States. So as much as we point and say,
how do they believe this stuff? It's probably
a worse problem here in the United States.